James web James web telescope there's
been a lot of media uh reports
suggesting that the findings of the
James web telescope have undermined the
case for The Big Bang but there's an
interesting backstory on this most of
these media reports were based on the
writings of a single physics researcher
named Eric larner who's been since 1990
kind of carrying a torch uh to refute
the Big Bang one of his his articles
quoted a university of Kansas
astrophysicist uh saying that she stays
up late at night wondering if based on
the on the the James web that everything
that we
know is turning out to be false turns
out that that researcher uh that that
astrophysicist disclaimed his use of the
quote explaining that he took it
completely out of context that she was
talking about theories of Galaxy
formation not about whether or not there
had been a big bang and not about
whether or not the universe is expanding
as we would expect so he's confirmation
bias yeah conf and and in a sense also
taking somebody way out of context to
make a point of his own you know he he
he misused the quotation on purpose
apparently and there have been a number
of leading astrophysicists in fact
people who would like you know to know
more about this I'd recommend Brian
keing from University of California San
Diego great astrophysicist has been
writing about this and but here here's
the short story I wrote a an oped in the
daily wired distilling some of this
stuff what the James web telescope is
able to do is to in fact was what it was
constructed to do was to detect
extremely long wavelength radiation
stuff that's outside the visible range I
call it Uber red shifted the te it's
actually in the infrared range is the
more uh accurate physics uh term so it's
looking for very long wavelength uh
radiation coming from galaxies that are
very very far out there now why would it
be looking for that well because if the
universe is expanding as we would expect
based on the Big Bang the Theory then
the the radiation coming from things
very very far out in space and therefore
very far back in time should be very
stretched out more stretched out than
stuff that's closer at hand uh so the
James web was constructed in hopes of
detecting that type of radiation if it
existed it's not assuming that it
necessarily would but it would be a way
of confirming the expansion of the
universe has been going on for a very
long time and in order to do that the uh
NASA people created an amazing
technology they super cooled the
detection techn or the detection
apparatus to I think five six seven
degrees above absolute zero so that the
heat coming off of the instrument itself
was not creating infrared that would
that would uh interfere and what they
were in fact able to detect from these
very ancient very distant galaxies was
super red shifted radiation Uber red
shifted stuff out in the infrared and
we're able on the the basis of that to
synthesize images of these very very
distant remote galaxies now the very
fact that they were able to do that
confirms that you have that what you
would expect on the basis of the Big
Bang Fury that you would that the amount
of red shift that you would expect to be
present if in fact the galaxies had been
expanding throughout that vast stretch
of time was in fact present and was
detected now that didn't get reported
there were what the whole Focus was on
the fact that there were galaxies that
were more mature there were more of them
early on than we would have expected
based on our theories of Galaxy
formation and so those are anomalies
that need to be addressed and have not
yet been explained as I understand it
maybe the astrophysicist have made more
progress on that in even recent recent
days but the basic picture of an
expanding Universe outward from the
beginning has not been undermined but
rather confirmed in a very dramatic way
I think it's a rather dramatic
confirmation there have been many others
the cosmic background radiation that was
discovered in 1965 the Kobe radiation of
George that George smot discovered in
the 90s so there's been this pattern of
confirming evidence of this basic
picture of an expanding Universe out
from the beginning in in observational
astronomy from the 20s right up till now
and so that I think gives us good reason
to think best we can tell the universe
at a beginning can I pause you on that
what is the the when she was discussing
the the formation of galaxies what what
had thrown that into question like what
what was about the formation of galaxies
that undermined previous ideas as I
understand it it's that there were are
more galaxies that formed earlier and
are more mature than we would have
expected because they were able to do
look back to 13.5 13.6 billion years ago
they think the origin of the universe is
about 13.8 billion years ago so
apparently galaxies were forming faster
than we would have expected and I think
that's the anomaly that is on the table
but is it possible that with further
further detection we can with new data
have a better understanding of what is
actually going on rather than just
saying it all points to this thing yeah
it's always possible that we can change
our minds on things because science is
always provisional but there are many
stable theories that have persisted
because of a preponderance of evidence
that points to and continues to point to
the same conclusion and I think we've
had a hundred years now where we've had
repeated new types of observations that
point towards a beginning